THINK.
GUESS WHO IS NEXT?
SEAN HANNITY FROM NEW YORK.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A LOT TO COVER
TONIGHT.
BREAKING RIGHT NOW WITH JUST
HOURS TO GO UNTIL THE SCHIFF
SHOW MOVES TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
OF COURSE, THE PSYCHOTIC
TRUMP HATING IMPEACHMENT
HEARING RAGE WHICH IS REALLY
NOT AND I WILL EXPLAIN IN A
MINUTE HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE
FINALLY RELEASED THE
DOCUMENT OUTLINING THEIR
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THE SO-CALLED TRUMP-UKRAINE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY REPORT.
IT'S REALLY JUST A COUP
REPORT.
NOTHING BUT AN INSANE
CONVOLUTED 14,000 WORD
DIATRIBE CONCOCTED BY THEIR
FEARLESS COMPROMISED,
CORRUPT, COWARD, CONGENITAL
LIAR THAT WOULD BE ADAM
SCHIFF, THEIR LEADER.
REPORT IS CHOCK-FULL OF
NOTHING BUT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
LEFT-WINGS OPINIONS,
CONJECTURE, HEARSAY
WITNESSES, COMPLAINTS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S FOREIGN
POLICY BY PEOPLE THAT THINK
THEY ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT
AND A WHOLE LOT OF OUTRIGHT
LIES.
AND, YEAH, TWO QUOTES:  FROM
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND
ALEXANDER HAMILTON, THEY ARE
EVEN DRAGGING THEM THROUGH
THE MUD.
THIS IS NOT A SERIOUS
DOCUMENT.
IN FACT, THE ONLY CLEAR
PIECE OF RELEVANT REAL HARD
EVIDENCE IS THE TESTIMONY
FROM THEIR ONLY ONE DIRECT
WITNESS.
THAT GUY RIGHT THERE,
AMBASSADOR GORDON SONDLAND.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT,
QUOTE, I'M READING:  ON
SEPTEMBER 9TH SONDLAND
CLAIMED THAT THE PRESIDENT
ANSWERED AN OPEN QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT HE WANTED FROM
UKRAINE WITH AN IMMEDIATE
DENIAL.
I WANT NOTHING.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
THAT IS THE ONLY PERSON
UNDER THE FEDERAL RULES OF
EVIDENCE, NOT THE HEARSAY
WITNESSES, NOT THE OPINION
WITNESSES, THAT'S THE ONLY
GUY THAT COULD BE A REAL
WITNESS IN A REAL COURT OF
LAW.
THE OTHERS ADMISSIBLE, AND
MEANWHILE, THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY AGAIN
THIS WEEKEND, ASSURED
EVERYBODY NEVER FELT ANY
PRESSURE, NO QUID PRO QUO.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU PEOPLE
YOU?
ARE NOT LIKELY GOING TO HEAR
THIS ON FAKE NEWS, CNN OR
YES AREA 51 ROSEWELL RACHEL
MADDOW'S CONSPIRACY CHANNEL
SND
SMDNC.
LOOK, NO QUID PRO QUO.
LOOK, I NEVER TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT OF A POSITION OF A
QUID PRO QUO.
KEEP IN MIND PRESIDENT TRUMP
INVITED ZELENSKY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THREE
SEPARATE OCCASIONS WITH ZERO
STIPULATIONS BEFORE THE 9TH,
YEAH.
PROBLEMATIC FOR THEM.
U.S. AIDE TO UKRAINE WAS
PAID OUT IN FULL.
WHEN DID THEY MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THEY WERE
DOING THE THINGS THAT TRUMP
WAS DEMANDING?
THEY NEVER DID.
AND TO TOP IT ALL OFF.
THAT AIDE WAS NEVER
DISCUSSED IN MULTIPLE PHONE
CALLS BETWEEN ZELENSKY AND
TRUMP.
AIDE NEVER TALKED ABOUT.
AGAIN, NO ONE, NO ONE EVER
TESTIFIED THAT DONALD TRUMP
TOLD THEM TO WITHHOLD AIDE
FOR ANY POLITICAL FAVOR THAT
WOULD ONLY BE QUID AND
PRO-AND JOE WITH US ON
HUNTER.
PAID MILLIONS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS AND LET'S
NOT LOSE SIGHT OF SOMETHING
VERY IMPORTANT.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR'S
RAMBLING REPORT WAS RELEASED
JUST HOURS BEFORE THE FIRST
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING THERE IS
NO TIME TO MOUNTS ANY LEGAL
DEFENSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN'T EVEN
IN THE COUNTRY AND THEY KNEW
THAT, TOO.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
CONGENITAL LIAR.
THE COMPROMISED ADAM SCHIFF
WHO CONDUCTED THE
INVESTIGATION WROTE THE
REPORT, HE IS A KNOWN,
REPEATED CONGENITAL LIAR.
HE LIED REPEATEDLY ABOUT
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
WE HAVE ALL THE EVIDENCE.
FOUR INVESTIGATIONS, NO
EVIDENCE.
HE LIED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL.
HE HAD TO MAKE IT UP WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY AND
UKRAINE.
IN FACT, HE MADE UP AN
ENTIRE FAKE TRANSCRIPT AND
THE CONGENITAL LIAR EVEN
LIED ABOUT HIS CONTACT WITH
THE NON-WHISTLEBLOWER-
WHISTLEBLO
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER-WHISTLEBLO
WER-WHISTLEBLOWER.
HIS OFFICE WAS COMMUNICATING
WITH THE FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OH,
I FORGOT TO TELL YOU THAT.
AND NOW LOOK AT THIS.
BREAKING TONIGHT, ACCORDING
TO MAJOR REPORT FROM
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
CARRIE PICKERINGTON,
WASHINGTON EXAMINER, SCHIFF
ACTUALLY HIRED A NORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY AIDE WHO
WORKED WITH THE NAMED
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER.
THE UKRAINIAN WHISTLEBLOWER
ONLY ONE DAY AFTER THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL WITH
UKRAINE.
AD CORDING TO THE REPORT,
QUOTE:  THE PAIR HAD A
CLOSE, QUOTE, BRO LIKE
RELATIONSHIP WHILE WORKING
AT THE NFC TOGETHER.
NOT ONLY WAS THE CONGENITAL
LIAR'S OFFICE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER HEARSAY
WHISTLEBLOWER BUT THEY EVEN
HIRED THE FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER'S WORK BRO
RIGHT THE DAY AFTER THE CALL
IN QUESTION.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS ALL ONE
BIG COINCIDENCE.
ARE YOU?
AND TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD A FEW CHOICE WORDS FOR
THE COMPROMISED CORRUPT
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK ADAM SCHIFF IS A
DERANGED HUMAN BEING.
GREW UP WITH A COMPLEX.
VERY SICK MAN.
HE LIES.
ADAM SCHIFF MADE UP MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
THIS GUY IS SICK HE MADE UP
THE CONVERSATION.
HE LIED.
IF HE DIDN'T DO THAT IN THE
HALLS OF CONGRESS HE WOULD
BE THROWN IN JAIL.
HE DID IT IN THE HALLS OF
CONGRESS AND GIVEN IMMUNITY.
THIS IS A SICK PERSON.
IS HE A LIAR.
>> Sean: DERANGED HUMAN
BEING SUBMITTED HIS PILE OF
FINDINGS TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
OH YEAH THEN WE HAVE KNOW
NOTHING NADLER ATTEMPT TO
RUSH THE IMPEACHMENT SHAM
ACROSS THE LINE AND GET IT
DONE FOR CHRISTMAS.
NADLER IS LIKELY JAMMING
IMPEACHMENT DOWN ALL OF OUR
THROATS.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING FOR
US FOR THREE YEARS EXCEPT
HATE ON DONALD TRUMP.
INVESTIGATE DONALD TRUMP.
TELL US HOW BAD DONALD TRUMP
IS.
TRUMP-RUSSIA, TRUMP RUSSIA,
UKRAINE, IMPEACH, IMPEACH,
IMPEACH.
LIES, LIES, STORMY, STORMY,
S-HOLE, S HOLE.
NO EVIDENCE.
FOUR INVESTIGATIONS, NO
TRUMP-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
NADLER SHOULD HAVE THE VOTES
TO DO PRETTY
TO DO WRETTY
TO DO WHATTY
TO DO WHATEY
TO DO WHATEVER HE WANTS IN
THE HOUSE.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING ARE
MAJOR POLITICAL
RAMIFICATIONS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, LOOK AT
THIS REPORT FROM THE
EXAMINER.
SOME BELIEVE NADLER IS EVEN
MORE UNLIKEABLE THAN SCHIFF.
YOU HAVE THE SCHIFF SHOW AND
NOW THE SCHIFF SHOW WITH A
GUY THAT'S MORE HATED THAN
HIM.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP ALREADY
SURGING IN THE POLLS.
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
ON A STEADY RAPID DECLINE
AND SOURCES NOW TELLING FOX
NEWS THAT.
>> Anna: IMPEACHMENT VOTE
WON'T HAPPEN BEFORE
CHRISTMAS BECAUSE OF COMPLEX
ISSUES LIKE PELOSI DOESN'T
HAVE THE VOTES AND DEMOCRATS
ARE HAVING A REALLY HARD
TIME STAYING FOCUSED.
LOOK AT THIS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTING SOME LAWMAKERS ARE
TRYING TO EXPAND THE
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES.
THEY EVEN WANT TO REVISIT
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
FOUR INVESTIGATIONS.
LET'S GO BACK TO THAT ONE.
THEY HAVE LOST TOUCH WITH
REALITY, LOGIC, REACH,
COMMON SENSE.
BIFURCATED THEIR BRAINS.
WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE A QUID
PRO QUO.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS UNLESS YOU
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR THAT I
HAVE BEEN TOLD IS
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCE SON THAT UKRAINE
OIL COMPANY IS PAYING
MILLIONS.
THERE YOU GO.
BUT THEY HAVE TO SHUT THAT
PART OF THEIR BRAIN OFF.
JUST LIKE THEY SHUT THE PART
OF THEIR BRAIN OFF WITH THE
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS AND
THIS IS THE ONLY GOOD NEWS.
IN 336 DAYS YOU, WE, THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY YOU
GET TO SHOCK THE WORLD
AGAIN.
WE GET TO -- WE GET TO DO IT
ONE MORE TIME 2016.
REMEMBER THEIR FACES
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP.
NOW PRESIDENT-ELECT.
IMAGINE THAT CNN FAKE NEWS.
MSDNC FAKE NEWS.
WE NOW PROJECT THAT DONALD
TRUMP HAS BEEN REELECTED THE
45TH PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED